because I'm just curious about like the
spirit of fighting like then this wood
it is inside of somebody that gives them
like that you know that ability like
well it depends it depends what you're
doing it for you know what I mean like
for me I left school of 16 in England I
came from a family love my mom and dad
daily but you know they work together
and you know it was a tough environment
it was it was a very very tough
environment as I said left school at 16
went straight into dead-end jobs working
minimum wage in factories one thing that
what shitty job the shittiest jobs I
could ever [ __ ] imagine really you
name it I've done em all yeah oh god
what are you doing over there anything
and everything you know driving a
forklift working in a slaughterhouse
[ __ ] [ __ ] furniture you know not
door-to-door sales
no double glazing no double glazing
windows doughnuts yeah you have much
more success selling double glazed
doughnut to me no yeah yeah exactly
you're right yeah no double glazed
windows well it solves a lot of them
it's not like a scam is it do you know
it's like modern windows you know double
glazed windows so what were you guys
using before that
just [ __ ] the single single glazed no
everyone else double glazed windows you
probably have double glazed windows and
anyway so he's trying to get people to
do that and I was never selling much
yeah I didn't think we were selling like
Oprah so back then I was way bigger way
bigger yeah and I had a shaved head and
you know yeah and I was at and my boss
was like you're not selling very much
Michael I'm like yeah it's like you
think you mean a bit intimidating at the
door cuz you're a pretty loud big person
I'm like no I don't think he's gonna buy
a glass window
yeah sign up so anyway yeah I did you
know all these shitty jobs and then you
know I'd met my wife and we had two kids
and I was working as a quality control
inspector at a furniture store Furniture
Factory and my boss there a great guy
nice guy very intelligent and we would
chat away and he used to say to me say
Michael you're a smart kid is this what
you want to do for the rest of your life
well I was like [ __ ] know if I'll ever
think about what you want to do have a
thing and then come back to me in talks
because you don't wanna do this for you
rest of your life I'm like yeah no
anyway a few days pass so there was
so as some guy not too energetic not
Paige but I'm curious about this so it
was like somebody it was actually a guy
who's yeah hopped you and said it was a
guy he was my Foreman it were and you
really trusted this guy yeah I'm you
looked up to him yes yeah it was a nice
guy you know interesting how when you're
young especially if you're a young man
like you know I didn't have like a lot
of like father figures in like that
around so any man that would give me
like attention or like show actual
interest you know that wasn't a damn PDF
file or someone if you have those in
your country but no unfortunately we do
I think they are universally okay around
we should make them fighting yeah yeah
100% I'd buy that paper sanction that
one dude I'd call me Kellerman in that
one yeah yeah yeah what Sam but um but
so I can just imagine like the effect
that that has like when some guy like
shows you interest in his like here have
a think about what you want to do it
really resonated with you yeah for me I
was always had and I always had a
problem with authority figures right
always that kid I had too much to say I
was a loudmouth I was always getting in
trouble you know I was an idiot I was it
was a dick you know and this guy he knew
how to speak to me he was a nice guy and
he and he said that to me said you think
about what you want to do and
fortunately the job didn't require much
brain power so I it gave me a lot of
time to think and I thought about it and
I went up to him one day I said make
I've decided what I want to do and he
put down his clipboard and he came off
when he's like what is he and he thought
I was gonna see how kids I'm gonna go to
school I'm gonna study to be this that
and the other and I said and this is
2003 I said I'm gonna be a professional
fire and he was like oh my god I thought
you were smart I thought what do you
mean you've gotta be a professional fire
I might make I should do a lot of
martial arts okay that and he's looking
at me like what are you talking about
what is this I think I gave this
[ __ ] three weeks to think about
that's exactly and I'm like no seriously
me trust me I was very good and I
brought in this whole kickboxing video
of me
kickboxing he's like oh yeah alright you
know they said that was just fueled of
aggression and the guy sucked yeah I
know but you know anyway so we're so
yeah quit work I moved to another city
started training
the rest is history Wow watching that
video right there that was a beautiful
little segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe subscribe